you're embarrassing yourself that's
probably why people would I don't think
so all right embarrassing yourself
gentle shame to the queen you know what
I tell you who's really embarrassing
they're not a member yourself
stupid sod I tell you he's not a member
of the queer Community
embarrassing himself but but the entire
thing the lgbtqia plus the fact that
there's more and more people who are
coming under this particular and that is
not a real thing it's [__]
total horseshit and I'm just one of
things that's very annoying in this era
is that they're just these steaming
piles of horseshit in front of us all
and and we're all meant to sort of
shovel our way through them I just don't
have time and I might pay somebody else
to shovel the whole [__] for me but like
I just don't have time for this crap I
don't have time for people to keep
adding letters to I don't my view has
always been there's no such thing as a
gay community anyway and that's just the
gays lesbians and gays don't get on
famously have very little in common
uh both are very suspicious of bisexuals
have nothing to do with transgender
there is no bigger chasm in the world
than gay men and asexuals
none
like the idea that in a bar in a gay bar
like you know you'd be like hey your
heart I'm asexual
uh I don't know they have their own
hookup apps where they don't meet
um there's just nothing that keeps you
as far away from other people yeah
exactly exactly and it keeps people's
clothes on yeah and and then there's
just then there's ones like uh the queer
one well Queer as far as I can see is
only I did a bit of this amount of
crowns but it only means either ooh look
at me I'm fascinating no you're not you
you dyed your hair purple you're boring
um or it's
um I'm straight but I want a bit of the
intersectional pie so I'll go like oh
I'm queer there was a guy at Oxford who
was teaching who said that and he was
just like oh one of my students came
over and said it's so nice to see myself
represented you know by a lecturer and I
think this guy like painted his nails or
some crap like that and uh he he's a
straight guy he's married to a woman
oh you don't want to queer and queer
used to be an insult to gay people it
still is an insult to gay people and
then it's appropriated by some straight
guys and girls because they think it'll
make them interesting find another way
to be interesting
um it's it's sort of a grotes man the
the uh the uh the alphabet people stuff
doesn't really interest me I just say
you know get on with their lives they
bored me enough you know but there's
also the fact as well that do you know
and I've spoken to quite a lot of gay
men about this and they all mutter under
their brush that they actually find it
profoundly irritating with the queer
thing where they go if you do blackface
that is seen as the most heinous form of
racism unless you're just introduced
unless you're just intrude on which case
it's method but um
but
that being the case if I come out and go
I'm queer and you know I've never even
had any form of sexual interaction with
a man that's fine yeah queer face is
fine yeah it was like it's like Woman
face it's fine yeah you can pretend to
be a woman and it's not insulting to
women
I don't agree I think it's very
insulting but I can't spend any more of
my life being upset by morons yeah just
uh particular attention seeking morons
look at me look at me yeah I've got
other things to do there's books I
haven't read
foreign